now is there ever a chance we get to see
ksi and you in the ring
man
people love playing i'm ready right
and i'm ready
and the kid has been avoiding me for
three years and even his own fans now
are just like dude stop stop talking
about it because
he clearly
doesn't want to do it wouldn't that be
bad for business
for him to lose now that he's in
business with your brother with like the
prime stuff
no i mean i'm sure they would try to
like promote it through the fight and
[ __ ]
but at the end of the day i think it's
just too much of a risk for him
you know i don't think
he actually wants to take the risk in
fighting me with having the potential to
lose
um
because again he talks about it all the
time i've said i'll fight you in london
i set out
you know you could be the a side
whatever terms you want like i don't
really i don't give a [ __ ] i just want
to knock you the hell out and he just
won't do it and then is tweeting me for
the past two years all the time click
baiting me on youtube damn near his
whole entire social media strategy is
just to talk about me
and
my manager gets on the phone with his
and they never want to fight
really
where does it break down
well i mean
for him it's like
i think he knows he's gonna lose
yeah but i mean like so he put some
unrealistic he put some unrealistic
things so the fight doesn't happen where
does it break down it's not the money it
seems
he doesn't even put on realistic terms
he just doesn't actually want to fight
so he doesn't even get to the terms
no it doesn't like one of the excuses i
think i was asking what's the kind of
[ __ ] he'll say like oh well i can't do
it because this i'm doing my music tour
and
i'm busy like bro you're selling out 800
person rooms
like no one gives a [ __ ] about your
music
little
banks bro
over the course of a weekend that's
pretty good you know what i mean
when you have like 80 million followers
that he has yeah and you're doing 800
person rooms yeah that's the day like
it's like oh wow
your music sucks like get the hint right
and now all the influencers are trying
to box because they see jake paul made
45 million dollars last year is that how
much you made yeah and ksi
and
[Laughter]
yeah good for you thank you man good for
you
thank you it's uh why are you still
fighting that's what i'm wondering right
now 45
as much as it's not about as much as it
is about the money at the same time it's
not but like i said it's like you like
it i [ __ ] love it i need it and
i i don't want to be doing it when i'm
like 30. yeah yeah you know
imagine being washed up in 30. you know
what is 30 like you have your whole
pants
stupid age dude
[Applause]
yeah yeah yeah the ct [ __ ]
yeah there was i mean after the woodley
fight maybe the first or second one i
think you said like i'm done i'm not
gonna box for a while at least i'm gonna
take some time off and then you didn't
what keeps bringing you back
i can't stay out of the gym man like
it's an addiction yeah i just wanna
a week after the fight i just put on the
running shoes and just
go for a jog and then after that i just
can't stop and i know
that there's people out there gunning
for me that want to see me lose and that
are motivated to train to come and beat
me and this is the opportunity of a
lifetime
and you know playing my cards right you
know you look at where conor mcgregor
was at my age and it's nowhere near
where i am now so
the potential is unlimited to become the
biggest and greatest prize fighter in
the world and i said i would do that two
years ago
um and that's just been my motivation
ever since is
setting the [ __ ] insane goal and just
riding it until the wheels fall off so
is the goal to be the biggest prize
fighter or do you want to also be
champion do you care about the belts at
all
the goal is to be the biggest prize
fighter and
to win a world championship in my last
fight
and then walk away and then walk away
what division 175 pounds you come down
to 175 yeah light
yeah
heavyweight
saw a clip on tick tock i don't know who
it was with but the guy was [ __ ] talking
to you about your boxing ability and you
said i'm glad you said that because when
i'm world champion i want you to eat
your words
there's no way you thought when you
started i'm gonna be world champion was
there a moment where you're like yo i
could be [ __ ] world champion um
when i sparred my first world champion
who steve cunningham oh wow big
three-time world champion yeah
cruiserweight uh this was
a year ago a year and a half ago yeah um
steve is bigger than that steve is big
bigger than me steve fought it with me
yeah not knocked down tyson fury that's
right um and he was he was a little too
light to be fighting those heavyweights
exactly but he still [ __ ] did a great
very skilled big guy yeah dope guy dope
guy shout out to steven um
he was the first like multiple time
world champion there's like fake world
champions of boxing he was the first
like real real world champion that i
sparred up against and
did phenomenal really um he said it
happened to you after he you know he was
he was blown away he said he's just like
bro you're going to be all right really
you're going to be all right you know
our guy uh did uh shout out to jake
boswick and i asked him about it and he
was very complimentary yeah yep no jake
jacobs he's a great fighter as well yeah
great spawn okay so you start to fight
these pro guys right and i'm sure
there's guys on the come up too that
you're like sparring with now is it like
hey let's go light or is it like some
philadelphia
dog house like we're just going at it
full goal
time no no holding back i like to go
harder in sparring to prepare myself for
the fight night oh wow is there ever an
issue with the sparring partners where
they're like hey buddy we we're just
kind of getting some work in here no we
don't we don't keep around people like
that really no yeah i i only spar
people who are better than the person
that i'm gonna fight
so you haven't been knocked down never
been knocked down really not once never
in sparring and that's why again it goes
back to like the confidence in myself to
talk all this [ __ ] because it's like if
these world champions who i've sparred
full-on
can't hurt me then